leader conference for the World Cup
squad announcement as you can see we've
got Gareth to Southgate with us so we'll
get started straight away with Rob
Dorsey from Sky Sports News
Gareth nice to see you on a big day a
day when you've broken some hearts and
and you've made a number of players
dreams come true I suspect um but
crucially before we get into the
individuals and the decisions that
you've made when you look at that Squad
of 26
do you believe it has everything in
there needed to win a World Cup
yeah that we we've wanted to make sure
we've got the balance of the squad right
I think
in this day and age Squad is more
important than ever we're now five
substitutes you can have almost half the
team changed during your game so
you want different options for different
moments of matches
um and for different stages of the
tournament as well
um we've obviously had to cover a couple
of players that aren't yet fully fit for
the match fit as well so having 26
available meant that we were probably
able to take a couple of risks that you
might not have been able to with 23.
um but we think the balance is there and
we've got covering the positions we need
we're we're lighter on depth in some
positions than other in in our country
um but we think we've got everything
covered
we said widely across every bit of the
media I think before you pick your squad
that James Madison would be the headline
story whether he was in or whether he
was out
he's in why is he in
he's playing really well
um look he's a good player we've always
said he's a good player he's earned the
right
um he
we think he can give us something
slightly different to the other
attacking players that we've got so I
think at various stages there have been
conversations debates about James
there's been moments where
you know ahead of the eurozzy I don't
think he was in contention he had a bit
of a problem with his hip and then
I think September was probably a fair
debate but I think he's playing as well
as any of the attacking players in this
country and
um yeah he is a little bit different to
the others we've got different types of
threat and I think we could need that
uh did you speak personally to Callum
Wilson was he absolutely delighted I
haven't had a chance with Callum I did
speak to James because I think this
morning there was a lot of speculation
that James wouldn't be with us and we'd
decided a couple of weeks ago that we
would but we weren't obviously going to
go and tell him then
um I didn't get a chance to speak with
Callum my priority always on these days
is the difficult conversations and the
sad news and that is really tough you
know there's
um not many situations in football
harder than that maybe releasing a young
player
um at the early stages of their career
but
the the nature of those conversations
good and bad reminds you of how much it
means to a player to go to a World Cup
and um yeah I'm very conscious of that
so it is a great day but also for some
I've had to disappoint them one of those
is Tammy Abraham I suspect and you've
gone for Wilson ahead of Tammy Abraham
what was that discussion and debate like
in your mind yeah look
um
Tommy's had a a poor run of scoring form
at the wrong time really and
it's not a case where we're
three four weeks away from the finals
and and the start of the first match
we're now 10 days and so
form could be more important I think we
don't really know any of the players
we're watching
um their Club form but we don't really
know where they are until we see them
face to face until we see them on the
training pitch
we get regular medical updates from all
their clubs but there'll be medical
issues that we're not completely aware
of yet
we know the form we're seeing in the
matches but even so you you still don't
get the full picture from the players
until you're able to speak with them
work with them and see how they train
with each other
you hinted that you wanted extra cover
for players that might be struggling
with injury and obviously Calvin
Phillips and Carl Walker are the two
obvious ones there how are they how big
a gamble is it to include them in this
squad and can we assume that neither can
really play a part in the in the opening
game
uh no that's not the case I mean Calvin
played last night
um so I think with him he's free of
injury the
um we are aware that
um he's not going to be able to play 790
minutes that that won't be possible
um we're going to have to build his
Fitness level
um but he's available he's free of
injury and we don't really have
you know we we have Declan rice as a
defensive midfielder
hendo can play there but it's not his
number one position
um so we don't have a lot of cover for
that role in the country and Calvin is a
super player and we feel that
um you know that's a risk worth taking
because he's also generally his Fitness
is good
um and yeah we we think he can add to
the group and Kyle similarly Kyle a
little bit different in that he's not
back in full training yet but he he's
going to be available before the end of
the group stage and of course we had to
make a very difficult call with Rhys who
we think is a fantastic player
but he wasn't going to be available
until if everything went perfectly until
the latter stages of the tournament and
there were too many unknowns for us on
that road to recovery and also I don't
think we can take a player who's not
available for the group that would be
deemed arrogant in some circles but also
either then be dropping If he if
everything went well and he was
available and he was ready and we were
picking him then he'd be dropping him
into a quarter final after eight weeks
out and that's that would be really
demanding so yeah tough call Kyle is a
long way ahead of that and is
progressing really well thank you Carrie
hello Gareth um can we look at Harry
MaGuire a player that's struggling to
get minutes but has been a stallwall for
you what was your decision-making
process and how much have you been in
touch with Manchester United about what
he's doing when he's not getting those
playing minutes and uh will he be
considering him as an out and out
attacker after he's uh playing time
alongside Ronaldo against Russia
well physically we've had really good
communication with all of the clubs in
this period on the training loads of all
of the players because we've got to pick
that up immediately on uh well it'll be
Wednesday before we see them on the
training pitch
um so we needed to know those who are
playing what's their load those who are
playing less regularly some have had a
unbelievably intense schedule some have
had less so so we're picking up various
Fitness levels and we've got to get that
right on the training pitch
um
yeah I mean uh we've picked
um our more experienced Defenders and we
think that at this moment in time the
younger ones have got some really good
qualities but
um we don't think they've quite done
enough to push the more experienced ones
out and we think the
tournament we're going into and the
level of the matches that that needed to
be the pecking order you've always said
that Trent Alexander Arnold is an
outstanding player always in
consideration but he didn't start in the
games building up to this announcement
what conversations did you have with him
and what's been his reaction that he is
now in the squad no as I said really the
only phone calls I've made have been to
um the two Lads that are coming back
from injury
the boys I left out of the squad and
then to James because
um you know I felt that was a an
important call to make this morning
the rest of the guys you know there's
only so many hours in the day and we've
been monitoring Fitness monitoring
matches
um dealing with so much so I think
they'll be delighted they'll get the
news and um yeah we've got plenty of
time to chat over the next few weeks
and for you now going forward when
you've got a real balance between the
experience of the players the 12 that
have been to a World Cup before and and
the rest of this squad and this this
quick turnaround is that exactly why
you've brought the likes of Harry
MaGuire back in when they haven't had
those match minutes
yeah he's one of our best center-backs
so
um
I think we we know
um within the squad we've got a lot of
players that we know have been to
tournaments have performed at the level
know what's required
um we've got other players who are
playing well who are in
um
form right at this moment and we've got
to balance all of that when we're
picking our team
you didn't call up James Madison in the
last Camp hasn't played a few years now
for England a lot of people would have
assumed that's because one of the camps
he missed because he was ill and then
was seen in a casino watching the match
she said at the time well that would
just remind him of the scrutiny of being
an England player have you did you have
a conversation about that again or on
his form is it just unnecessary no I I
didn't have
that was unfortunate from his
perspective in that
um it became a bigger issue than it was
for me because of uh you know you end up
in the papers nobody likes that I live
with it every day so I don't I don't
take any notice of it but
um for me that wasn't the drama that it
seemed to be for everybody else
um he's always been up against some
really good players in that area of the
pitch and there's been moments where
we were playing four three three no
number 10 type profile and that didn't
necessarily fit
um but he's he's as I said earlier he's
playing exceptionally well
um we like the fact that he finds those
pockets of space he gets turned he plays
forward not enough players play forward
in this day and age
um and of course his set play delivery
is outstanding
um and he can score goals from distance
which against low block defenses is a is
another attribute that is a little bit
different to some of our other players
it's Kerry we'll go to John Murray from
the BBC
hi Gareth you got me yeah can you give
us a flavor of what James Madison's
reaction was when he answered and you
told him the news
yeah he was he was delighted and um
as I said I had some very difficult
calls that were emotionally at the other
end of the spectrum so
yeah it was nice to give myself a little
bit of a uh an enjoyable end to that
because you know I'm excited about going
to a World Cup it's my fourth and um you
know that's a that's a privilege and an
honor and
um all of those calls the the difficult
ones and the really enjoyable ones were
a reminder of what it means to the
players and what would you say this 26
that you've chosen this time has got
that makes it stand out from the other
two big squads you've picked for for the
World Cup and the Euros
I think I think they've all been good
squads I mean in 2018 we were at the
start of something where we hadn't won a
knockout game for 10 years and
um there was a little bit less
experience perhaps within the group of
big matches
um I think this is similar in terms of
its standing to the to the group that
went to the euros and um
yeah of course within that period of
time from the start to the end of that
some players have moved on age-wise some
players haven't progressed in the way
they might have done new players young
players have emerged that have that have
given us great competition for places in
most areas of the pitch so
um we're excited by the group we think
there's a lot of
exciting Talent within it
um but the whole group have got to come
together you know there's a lot of
challenges it's a unique situation for
everybody this tournament the timing of
it
um and the obstacles just to get to this
point medically as much as anything so
um we've got to adapt better than
everybody else in this in this coming
period
thanks
hi Gareth um have the fa and the players
come to a collective decision about what
you will do or say if members from the
lgbtq plus Community are victimized in
any way during this particular World Cup
and as a follow-up question Iran is your
first match of this competition they
have been supplying the likes of Russia
with Weaponry should they be at this
world cup
so regarding the LGBT community
um we stand for inclusivity and we're
very very strong on that we think that's
important in terms of all our supporters
and we understand the challenges that
that this tournament brings within that
if it wasn't for the strength of that
Community we wouldn't be women's
European Champions
so it's very very important to us
um
with Iran
um
that's a political situation that I
don't know enough about to be able to
comment so those decisions have to be
taken by governing bodies and um yeah I
can't comment with enough authority to
give you a really considered View
FIFA faster Nations don't talk about
anything other than football when the
football starts will you be going along
with that I think that's highly unlikely
um you know I think we
have always spoken about issues that we
think should be talked about
particularly the ones we feel we can
affect
I think contrary to
one or two
observations in the last few weeks we
have spoken in the same way that other
nations have spoken about this
tournament and the human rights
challenges we've been very clear on our
standpoint on that
um so yeah look I think we would also
like to focus primarily on the football
this is for every player and every coach
and everybody traveling to a World Cup
this is a carnival of football it's the
thing you work for your whole life so
you don't want that to be diminished by
everything else that's going on around
it currently
um but we recognize that that we are
going to be in that situation and we've
got to accept and deal with it thank you
thank you thank you
foreign
others is it fair to say that Midfield
is one of those and and is it a
disappointment that you're that you
haven't had a lot of young midfielders
or midfielders of any type emerging as
real strong candidates for this squad
well to be fair Jude has obviously
emerged more in the last two years or 18
months since the Euros I mean we put him
in at 1718 so
um but look everybody says we've got
enormous depth but we're 31 of The
League last year so I know I talked
about that
periodically three four years ago I
think because the team have done well
that is masked that we've only got four
English goalkeepers playing in the
Premier League currently
um
left backs there aren't many playing
um we've got an unbelievable uh injury
list of fallbacks at the moment left and
right
um quite incredible and
yeah
sort of number six if you like the
defensive pivot Midfield player
um
is is also light in terms of actually
developing that position in our country
so you know Declan is really a converted
Defender
um and Calvin is sort of slightly
converted as well so
um yeah we we haven't uh produced that
type of player for a long time and it's
something that you know our academies uh
you know I think could
focus on but that's you know that's for
the longer term that's we've got the
players we've got we're happy with the
squad we've got we always have to find a
way of playing
to the best attributes of the players
we've got and we we can be exciting and
dangerous
um even though we don't have those types
of profiler players and um
Antonio Conte was saying last night that
Harry Kane is
tired exhausted I'm sure he is yeah is
that is that a concern
um for you not well particularly with
Harry but but with with all the players
that a lot of them do look tired or are
carrying injuries
yeah look again
I think I've stood here several times in
the last year and said this this world
cup everybody said This World Cup being
in the middle of the Season would be
better for us and I said we would lose
players sadly that has been the case
the schedule is what it is
um but we've got to refresh the players
we've got to excite them when they get
through the door we've got a period of
time where we won't set foot on the
training pitch when they arrive because
we'll travel on Tuesday so
we have got some that need to train
um and we've got some that will benefit
from a few days of of doing nothing but
get excited about playing for England
frankly so we we can only manage that
when the players are with us we
understand the challenges for the clubs
now and after the tournament and we've
just got to make sure we focus on the
bits we can control
um what have you learned from the Euros
that you can take into the World Cup and
why do you decide not to select uh James
Ward press
yeah with um with James
um he's really competing profile wise
with Bellingham and Henderson maybe to a
lesser degree Gallagher
um I don't see him in the same profile
as rice or Phillips they're different
types of players
um he's just behind those guys frankly
and uh it's as simple as that now we've
still got another round of games to get
through so I've spoken with a few of the
players to say that things can still
change over the weekend
um
from the Euros there's loads of things
we've learned loads of things we did
right loads of things that
um actually won't apply in this
tournament because it's a different time
of the year it's more condensed we don't
have warm-up games we're going to be
playing in different conditions heat
wise
so you're always learning from every
tournament but also there are unique
things around every tournament as well
and we've got to make sure that we weave
all of that together
and have you spoken to Ben White
no the only people I've spoken to are
the ones I've already uh
mentioned but I would imagine I hope
he's very excited about being involved
thank you James Ollie from ESPN hi
Gareth just following on from what you
just said there um could you give us a
bit more detail about the standby is
there a sort of a formal standby list
no we we had to name basically every
English player that was available on a
long list
um and um
there are some conversations I've had
with players in the last couple of days
where clearly they're going to be the
next ones in in their positions
um but then we just don't know what
might happen in in the next few days
um you know I I think there are two left
backs that got injured last night for
example so
um we've got to be fluid adaptable and
and ready for anything really just on
that how stressful is this weekend going
to be for you with these games
not for me
um there's nothing I can do about it so
you know the
watching the the matches unfold you're
always intrigued to see how the
tactical games are going the
performances the results the form of the
players of course
um but we can do nothing about the
injuries that's out of our hands we've
already been hit in that way it could
happen again but we've got to adapt
we've got good players to come in and
it'll be opportunities for others if if
we lost people
Thanks James so take one here just don't
decide here hi Gareth
um considering where the World Cup is
this year and some of the issues that
have been documented in Qatar will
England be taking the knee on a
worldwide stage
um United support and get behind some of
the black and mixed race players
yeah that would be a discussion we have
with the players when we get into Camp
um
and I'm always
um supportive of what they want to do I
have a view but I don't want to
influence them too much
because I think it's important that they
have a voice and they have a say in that
thank you can't see any more hands so oh
sorry we've got a
hit Brook from
hi Gareth um you you've talked in the
past about seeing Madison as a number 10
and the implications that had for the
formation that you might play can we
read anything into his selection into
the formations you might use in Qatar
well he he
um is obviously playing from the right
for Leicester uh his best work is in
that 10 slot that's where he ends up so
how how he ends up there is is different
I think
um
I think we've got to be flexible on our
systems because
um
everybody's always pushing do you know
your your best team sort of eight months
from a tournament and I've always said
we've got to be fluid because you just
don't know who you'll have
um we can't recruit like he would at a
club to a set system
um and even you know there are only a
probably a couple of teams in the league
that have been able to stick with a
preferred system of play and exact style
of play this season at the top end
um even some of the biggest teams have
had to change because injuries have
provoked them into changes of systems so
we've always had that flexibility we
think it's important we've got to look
at
who our best players will be and also
you know where are the where are the
flaws in the opponent to be able to
exploit them
do you want to come back in the last one
yeah one final one about about Conor
Gallagher
um who was a little bit of a surprise to
us but that that's because we know James
woolbrous is so well known tunes and so
well established
um what does Conor offer how do you
expect to use him because he's a little
bit more Forward Thinking than the
defensive midfielders you perhaps talked
about yeah but but also he's fantastic
at pressing the ball and um you know I
think there are going to be moments in
these games where we need certain
attributes and there are any number of
players in this squad with different
attributes to be able to utilize at
those moments and we feel he could be
um that sort of a player so he's not as
experienced with us as some of the
others but he has an impact in games
he's got a goal threat he
he's you know when you talk about
Midfield players you look at
did I stop goals do they create goals do
they score goals he does a little bit of
all of that actually so
um we were really pleased with the way
he responded to being
left out of our Squad went with the
under-20 ones and performed really well
his mentality was excellent and it's a
great example that if you approach it in
that way there's always a route back
with us and um and he's managed to
achieve that straight away
thank you we've got to have Matt Reed
hi Gareth
um so a number of our players are short
of their top form at the moment and
short of their top form with England
from recent performances or Fitness so
how how are we going to transfer
transform that over the coming weeks
before the first game and how key will
the group stages will be in in building
that confidence and building that form
essentially yeah I mean look
um
form can be temporary but you know that
that's
um a very individual thing and
um the key is the work on the training
pitch we don't have a long time to do
that
so we've got to see very quickly how
people present you know we've got a
pretty good idea of where people stand
at the moment but there's also there's
opportunity here because
um
there are there are players who are in
good form who could push their way into
the starting 11 and um we're not
steadfast on on n11 I think there are
some players that we're pretty certain
next week will be in that starting team
but there are a number of positions that
we want to have a look at and to see
exactly how people present
um
part of that is this schedule that
they're coming in off as well because
you know some have played every three
days for the last five six weeks
um and we we just don't know what the
impact of that's going to be
thank you and we'll finish with one from
Gabriel thanks very much Greg Gareth 21
of the 26 named were in the original
Euro Squad but what does that tell you
about the foundation you've got and is
the best yet to come from a group you
know so well
that um
we you know this if you get to the final
of a competition 18 months ago there
should be a fair amount of stability in
terms of
what that group were capable of on the
biggest stage
um but also room for people who are
playing well to come into the group and
we've always tried to work that way I
think you've got to
I know people
talk about being overly loyal but you've
got to have some consistency in your
thinking because it's hard to build
something without having that
consistency and then others can can come
in and Thrive so without doubt there are
a number of players who will be better
for the experiences they've already had
the key now is that we have to show that
on the biggest stage It also says that
it's been hard to break into this squad
well no I would argue that you know
across 18 months five is is quite a big
turnaround because
um
there's a there's only Conor in terms of
young ones who's who's come in I think
um into that I'm trying to trying to
think back 18 months
um we've looked at one or two others
there was a period where Emma Smith Rowe
had a go and was playing really well
he's absolutely lost him obviously we've
lost Rhys but Reese was with us in the
Euros so and and Ben
um but yeah look I I think
the most International or most teams
across a period of 18 months wouldn't
change much much more than four or five
players
okay thank you we'll leave it there
thank you Gareth thank you everybody and
we'll see you in Qatar thank you